- We're fucking fancy.
It's not that you can't,
it's that you're not
willing to give up dumb shit
for a better life.
You're not willing
to go backwards.
You're not willing to make
yourself dramatically happier,
to move out of your home
and downsize and go into
a different neighborhood.
You're not willing
to go backwards.
That to me is fascinating,
the fact that things, whether
home, car, watch, clothes,
going out,
is holding people back
from a substantially
happier life
is fascinating to me and
something that we
need to debate.
Because at the end of the day,
that one at-bat is all we got.
And so if I can absolutely
push you one tangible item,
I see some people
have pads and pens,
and I'm fascinated by that.
Go, ready?
Go to a fucking,
F-U-C-K-I-N-G,
retirement home,
spend time, collect data,
realize regret is the worst,
and do something about it.
(light music)